وباللجوء الى الدستور وكما كان متوقعا قرر
الرئيس الفرنسي
قرر تمرير مشروع قانون رفع سن التقاعد دون
موافقه البرلمان الذي شهد اعتراضا كبيرا
على القانون مكرون برر الاستعانه بالماده
49,3 من الدستور لتمرير القانون تجنبا لما
وصفها للمخاطر الماليه والاقتصاديه
الكبيره جدا على فرنسا القرار اتخذ
مشاهدينا بعد اجتماع ثاني عقد قبل ساعات
في الاليزي بين كل من ماكرون ورئيسه
الحكومه اليزابيث بالاضافه الى عدد من
الوزراء المعنيين فلنتابع
لا يمكننا المخاطره بمستقبل معاشاتنا
التقاعديه ان هذا الاصلاح ضروري ولانني
متمسكه بنموذجنا الاجتماعي ولانني اؤمن
بالديمقراطيه البرلمانيه فان الاصلاح بنص
البرلمان ثمره حل وسط بين المجلسين وانا
مستعده لتحمل المسؤوليه
لكن هذا لن يمر لن يمر طبعا مرور الكرام
وفق ما هددت به احزاب اقصى اليمين
الفرنسيه التي دعت عبر مارين لوبان الى
سحب الثقه من الحكومه انتقاما من تمرير
القانون كما دعت برفقه بقيه احزاب اليمين
الى تظاهرات كبيره حتى تحقيق كل المطالب
التي تتمثل بسحب القانون او سحب الثقه
القانون الجديد يقضي برفع سن التقاعد من
62 عاما الى 64 عاما في وقت تواجه في
فرنسا طبعا ازمات متصاعده بسبب ارتفاع
نسبه الشيخوخه في البلاد
[موسيقى]